I'm going to kill Aquaman
and destroy everything he holds dear
Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie.
This will be my Aquaman
2 teaser trailer video.
They surprised us
with an actual teaser trailer.
They were about to set the record
for how close a Warner Brothers
movie was going to get to release
before they actually started marketing it.
if I think
they actually dropped this trailer
because so many people were clowning on
them for not dropping the trailer, like,
how close are they going
to get to the movie
before
we actually see some footage from it?
there is a bunch of Easter eggs here.
They revealed some of the movie earlier
this year.
So we'll talk about that new footage, too,
during this video.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos,
Whatever they wind up releasing,
I will do videos for it.
Don't worry.
we do have the big James Gunn
reboot of the DC Universe.
I think the last time I did
an Awful Man to video that was long,
long before James Gunn had been hired
and before they had his whole plan
to reboot the DCU
with the DCU in Superman Legacy.
and I also did a video a little while ago
about Jason Momoa basically hyping up him
coming back
as a completely different DC character,
even though he keeps saying that
he'll always be Aquaman.
so there is a lot of questions about that.
Will he come back as a Lobo
in the new DCU movies or will he still be
a version of Aquaman when Aquaman
eventually shows up in the new movies?
alchemy had
just showed up in the Flash post-credits
scene on that new version of Earth
that the Flash created when he created
like a mini version of Flash Point
at the end of the movie.
But I don't think that that alchemy
is meant to be the one in this movie.
They weren't super clear on that.
But do not expect this Aquaman
to be referencing the events of the Flash
Post-Credits scene.
That's why I say it's probably going to be
a different version of Aquaman.
Like this one is meant to be
from the original Justice League Earth
before it got changed by the Flash.
they will release a much longer version
of this trailer later this week.
So I'll do another video
when they release that.
But starting with the new footage here,
the effects
they're using for the transitions
this blue here
might
just be a representation of the icebergs
that are hiding the lost
kingdom of Atlantis
Because it's supposed to be in Antarctica
or in the Arctic.
I'm not sure which one
There are seven kingdoms of Atlantis.
We only saw
six of them in the first movie.
So this movie is all about revealing
what happened to that Lost Kingdom.
They mentioned it in the first movie.
They said before the Lost
Kingdom had been lost
when they were talking about
the Great fall
when Atlantis sank into the ocean.
so Atlantis is the name of the city
where Aquaman is ruler,
but it's also the name of the nation
of Atlantis,
of a bunch of different kingdoms that
broke apart when it sank into the ocean.
it's Atlantis
itself, the city, Then Zebu where?
Mira and her father from the trench,
the brine, the fishermen in the deserters.
as the name implies, the deserters was
that desert location in the Sahara Desert,
where they went to find the information
on where to find the lost
so they could get king
at lands Trident in his armor for Aquaman
so that he could take the throne
This is all coming in on the shores
of some beach.
It could be an undersea beach
like the one in the first Aquaman movie.
This is him swimming through the Lost
Kingdom with a bunch of their soldiers.
This is him.
Still wearing the original suit
from the first movie.
This is traditional armor from the comics.
They're saying that it was meant
to be the ancient armor of King Atlan.
He's going to have
a couple different suits in the movie.
One of them is a stealth suit.
this looks like he's in the middle of
a fight with black Manta or someone else.
He might being Atlantis here, it's hard
to tell where he is because it does seem
there are a couple of big fight scenes
that happen in and around Atlantis.
there was a brand new scene
or an old scene
however you want
to think about it, of King Atlan fighting,
which probably has something to do
with the Lost Kingdom
also earlier this year, you may notice
when James Wan was teasing the movie,
he was posting pictures
when they were filming,
they were inside
what looked like an iceberg or a glacier
in the title or the working
title of the movie was Necklace.
So what is Necklace?
It's also called the black City.
It's basically a lost city
that's like Atlantis,
but it only exists on planet Earth
for brief periods of time.
It sort of shifts
between different dimensions.
And that's why it's lost.
Not only is it inside a glacier,
but it's also shifting between dimensions.
this is just awesome.
Versus black mantis men.
The undersea diving vehicles is might be
part of black mantis arsenal since Aquaman
or don't need vehicles like this
to survive deep underwater
there might be in black Mantis base here
the whole idea with AUM is he's
been in a prison
since the events of the first movie
Aquaman frees him and he helps him
defeat the Lost Kingdom of Atlantis.
Nicholas,
the king of that kingdom in black Manta
but then you see him after a haircut
in the same kind of gear
that Aquaman is wearing.
And they're both fighting black mantas
people together.
So even though
there's still a little bit of beef
between them,
it sounds like
they put most of the past behind them.
I think that was the idea
of the end of the first Aquaman film.
like, look, dude, we're brothers.
Let's put this behind us.
Water under the bridge
to make an alchemy and metaphor.
black Manta declares that he's going
to kill Aquaman with the help of Nicholas,
who gives him the upgraded Trident
and allows him to match
all command with Atlantis Trident.
So it basically just gets
a bunch of upgrades to his arsenal
that allows him to fight Aquaman
with his natural powers.
it looks like he destroys his father's
lighthouse home.
I'm not sure if he also winds up
killing Aquaman's father
or if he just winds up injuring him
really bad.
whereas in the Aquaman post-credits scene,
they revealed that he had been found
by Dr.
Steven Shin, who's an Aquaman
villain of sorts in the comics.
He's both an ally and a villain
to Aquaman, saves his life
and then basically vows his revenge.
so in service of that you probably notice
how everybody got redesigned
costumes, everybody got upgrades,
even Aquaman himself.
You think that the armor of King Outland
would be enough? No.
We need a bigger upgrade.
The whole thing with Black Mantis costume
is that it just got destroyed
in this fight with Aquaman.
so it makes sense that he wouldn't
want to retune his weaponry
his helmet, his armor
just to be a little bit better.
For the second round,
the whole thing with Aquaman's
brand new costume,
I know it looks kind of dark.
What's the deal here?
most people are referring to this
as his stealth armor, like
something is going on with the lost city
and he needs a stealth suit
for whatever mission they're going on.
movie is going to be really big,
so there'll be a couple submissions,
a couple side quests during this.
Do like you see them
running through the desert
like they go back
to the kingdom of the desert
to get more information
on the lost Kingdom.
so it's not like they're just going
between Atlantis in the Lost Kingdom.
They'll visit
some of the other seven Kingdoms as well.
We only briefly saw some of them
during the events of the first movie.
because the working title is Nicholas.
Nicholas is the Black City.
They're implying
that it's the lost kingdom of Atlantis.
In the comics,
the ruler of Nicholas was a person
named Mongo,
so I don't know if they're going
to change that for the movie
because in a big movie like this is silly
is they might get with some of
the moments as comedic a name like mongo
just feels a little too silly.
in in the comics his whole M.O.
was very similar
to Ocean Masters in the first movie,
you know, forming an alliance
to fight the surface dwellers.
but since we did that in the first movie,
I'm not expecting them
to recycle the plot of the first movie
for the second one.
This is him in the Arctic
or Antarctica on a seahorse.
this is meant to be his mother,
Elena, played by Nicole Kidman
from the first movie
battling a bunch of black mantis men
with the undersea submersibles.
What looks like necrosis man
from the Lost Kingdom.
this might be their big battle
in the movie,
like something on par
with the battle scene from the first movie
this might be Aquaman
defending Atlantis against Nicholas
and the other ocean creatures
he commands, like he's in Atlantis here
and they're attacking Atlantis
Like this looks like black mantis, man.
Maybe necklaces.
Man from the Lost Kingdom attacking
the highway into and out of Atlantis.
Like this is a big attack on Atlantis
itself.
all command on his throne.
The green glowing area here looks like
the lost kingdom being destroyed.
Later in the movie,
you can see the sheets of ice covering it.
this might be from Aquaman's final battle
with Black Manta using necklaces, Trident
Alchemy in here, using his powers
to call the Ocean Life to help.
not really sure
what he's doing with them
in this particular scene,
but he might be just calling them
for a major battle.
then they end with the logo,
the falling sheets of ice.
They're just meant to represent
the lost kingdom being unearthed.
Let me know in the comments, though,
if Jason Momoa is going to come back
in the new DC movies,
would you rather see him come back
as a version of Aquaman,
or would you rather him come back as Lobo?
Or do you think he's
actually going to do both?
because they could do a
Thanos situation with Josh Brolin,
who also plays
cable in the Deadpool movies,
even though he's not coming back
for Deadpool three.
Kevin Feige didn't seem like
there was a big problem with him
playing both Cable and Thanos,
because one of them was a big motion
capture performance.
they could also kind of do that
with a version of Lobo as Jason Momoa.
But I do feel like he would be
a pretty badass Lobo In the four years.
Four years ago,
I had the tip of five foot four.
Don't know. No,
I was, you know, four years ago.
I was screaming, wasn't screaming
when I left Warner Brothers,
everyone's in the mini
four years.
Again, it's a mystery, baby.
We got I got some really good news.
Great news with Warner Brothers.
Amazing.
Wish I could tell you, but here it is.
Peter, I love you, James.
I love you,
David.
Okay.
Back to the future.
To the future.
They're all pushing me rolling.
What was your meeting with James
Gunn and Peter Safran like?
It's very, very wonderful.
I'm in the house of Warner Brothers
and they like him
a lot of stuff I'm doing,
and we got a lot of good things going.
11 more months until we get another movie
we're going to have.
Yeah, we'll have Aquaman, which is funny.
It's the beautiful thing is I,
me and my partner wrote
the first treatment for
it is about a 55 page treatment
and a lot of it has to deal with,
you know, you talking to the U.N.,
expediting what's going to be happening
with the melting ice caps.
And it's there's no far off galaxy
coming in to destroy us.
There's no aliens from another place.
It's really
just the idea of us ruining our planet
and the fact that we all need
to get it together and save save our home.
So it's it's it's it's fun to see me
coming out and this this December.
And then,
you know, I'll always be Aquaman.
The rumors are I'll always be Aquaman
and want to go and take a shit.
And then there might be
some other characters too. So.
Oh, so we can play.
I can play other things too.
I can be funny and savage and charming
once in a while.
the other big thing of note in this movie
is the lack of Batman Post-Credits scene.
They shot a couple different
a couple different Batman post-credits
scenes with different versions of Batman.
There was one with Michael Keaton
when it was the previous regime at Warner
Brothers, then another regime came in
and they shot another post-credits
scene with Ben Affleck coming back,
getting rid of the Michael Keaton
Post-Credits scene.
Then James Gunn was hired
to reboot the DCU into the DCU
and they just completely got rid
of all the Batman Post-Credits scenes.
mostly because those post-credits scenes
were intended to set up things that
James Gunn didn't intend on paying off
because he was rebooting everything.
maybe we'll see the deleted scenes
of their post-credits
scenes at some point,
but I'm not expecting them
to put them on the Blu ray
or anything like that.
Maybe someone will leak
them. We'll get lucky.
when they post the much longer version
of the trailer later this week.
I'll do a video for that,
so be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
click.
Here to learn about Robin
showing up in the Batman 2 with Robert
Pattinson and click here for my Ahsoka
episode 5 Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!